un déploiement scénique il y a dix ans
jour pour jour ce petit robot à six
roues de la nasa débarque dans le
cratère gale sur mars l'euphorie est
totale
sa mission tenter de répondre à une
question précise la planète rouge at
elle été un jour habitables sur sa route
l'engin de 900 kg prend des milliers de
clichés sondent le sol martien ce qui
permet de détecter la présence de soufre
d'oxygène de carbone est essentielle à
la vie et de conclure que la planète
rouge était bien habitable il y à plus
de 3 milliards d'années évidemment on
parle ici de vie microscopique sous la
forme de bactéries non seulement on
avait l'idée qu'il y avait deux qu'il ya
eu de l'eau en abondance mais que
sait-on était sale et quelles étaient
leurs pendants suffisamment longtemps
pour
possiblement permettre l'apparition de
formes de vie curiosity a roulé sur 28
km scrutant notamment colline fond du
cratère est ni de rivières asséchées sa
mission entamée en 2012 ne devait durer
que deux ans la nasa l'a toutefois
prolongé jusqu'en 2025 le robot
s'apprête à explorer une région dont le
sol est essentiellement composé de
sulfate ce qu'il n'a pas encore étudié
et voir aussi quel genre de sulfate
c'est parce qu'on peut en avoir
plusieurs donc ça nous apprend c'est le
changement climatique en fait martial
et curiosity n'est pas le seul arpenter
la surface de mars le rover persévérance
l'a rejoint l'an dernier avec pour
mission la recherche de traces
prébiotiques et la collecte
d'échantillons qui seront apportées sur
terre
probablement la plus grande découverte
de l'histoire de l'humanité de constater
que la vie n'est pas une n'est qu'à la
terre d'ici là la réponse à ces deux
questions existentielles reste un
mystère ici daniel quatre jours radio
canada montréal